how is it for you getting into Anton cuz
we're used to seeing you and very much
more of an athletic or like you know a
domineering kind of role but here you
are you know you got this you got this
going on which is great new look for you
thank you sir you know I'm loving it
yeah I'm really enjoying it I I don't
know I just when I read the script it
just made it felt like I don't know
where it came from but I just felt that
this was the look of the character and
yeah I was fortunately able to convince
Kim our director that to go with this
look and I I felt like Anton he's very
cerebral
he's very on he's not very athletic at
all he is not very social he doesn't
care about his appearance or appearance
at all he's uh he loves coding yeah
writing code and coming up with great
algorithms that's what he you know
that's what that's fun to him so he on
stuff like we're seeing we're shooting
today it's a big family scene with
everyone and even though these are
people I mean his family people his kids
his wife you know it's people he loves
it's still yeah he'd rather be at home
by his computer and that's where he's
happy yeah I noticed you're you're
sitting there reading while you're
surrounded by all these people in the
scene this this concept of high
frequency trading is new to me what what
is that all about exactly well so the
concept of what they're trying to
accomplish is they're wanna you know
it's that they're trying to dig a tunnel
from Kansas City to New York to the New
York Stock Exchange and dig an optic
wire and by doing that you can beat
other traders who go through satellite
by something like 16 or 17 milliseconds
which doesn't sound like a lot but when
it comes to trading you know having that
advantage is huge yeah and someone
actually did this from it's never been
done from Kansas but someone did from
Chicago to New York City and made a lot
of money that way
because they're obviously stock markets
around the country in different cities
on and when you have that advantage
it's basically building a highway and
saying like come use my my highway gotta
it's the fastest way so they embarked on
this adventure where it's basically
basically mostly driven by Jesse's
character of Vincent he's uh he comes up
with the idea and my character is more
the brains of the operation the guy who
comes up with a coding who's trying to
like break this and figure it out how to
actually do it and that's how these two
cousins complement each other
Vincent is the outgoing the social guy
who's out there like fundraising shaking
hands signing contracts with landowners
so we can run this fiber on their on
their properties while my character is
in front of the computer you know
figuring out how to to optimize this
yeah I just been how cold it is outside
it seems like a really warm set how is
it working with Jesse you guys are
working in close quarters you guys are
together pretty much all the time ya
know it's been we're pretty deep in I
mean would this is where I think we're
on week seven now so we've been shooting
for a while and we didn't have much time
to prep it Jesse and I met about two
months ago in New York with Kim and just
had a day together who we sat and worked
on the script and talked about the
relationship and then we went our
separate ways I went to Spain to shoot
another project and Jesse went down to
Southern I think was in Kentucky and to
shoot another project and then we got to
bed we got together about four days
before we started the movie here in
Montreal so we didn't have much time to
prep but yeah we we just I don't know we
hit it off immediately and Jesse said I
don't know if you met him yet but he's a
very very sweet guy and lovely to work
with and very generous as a human being
and as an actor on set he cares
tremendously about my about the the
project and he knows his characters part
in that and and those are my favorite
actors to work with actors that care
more about the project and their egos or
themselves or how they're gonna be able
to
you know and so I think it's you know
it's been a great collaboration well
congratulations on the recent Emmy win
by the way thank you very much the the
the Golden Globe nominee on December the
11th are you gonna be paying attention I
mean if you kind of a shoo-in for this I
think I didn't know that that they're
dropping it but thank you for letting me
know and now I know I will be paying
attention to know I it was it was an
extraordinary weekend yes of course I
had such an amazing time on that project
and I got to work with some of the
greatest greatest actresses out there
and I was fascinated by and my character
and and to kind of develop that
relationship with Nicole was
extraordinary and they took komen and
you know not only to win but like the
just the the journey of like the one the
one that when the show aired and the the
it you know the how people would deeply
people were invested and cared about the
show and the characters and really meant
analyzed so and it was a very it was a
great weekend you know to go out and the
show got so much love and we had it had
a blast together on so in terms of the
globe's I honestly didn't know when that
was happening and I yeah I've I feel
like we've been more than rewarded yeah
yeah now your projects that you've been
doing are really interesting and
phenomenal can you tell us about the
next one here you're gonna be going from
working with Kim and working out with
Park chan-wook for a little drummer girl
which is very cool yeah yeah that I mean
we're just we just finalized that and
he's obviously an extraordinary
filmmaker I thought a handmaiden his
last film was spectacular and obviously
old boys yeah second on I haven't met
him yet we've Skyped a couple of times
on such an interesting man really really
smart his take on it is fascinating on
and it's an obviously based on a very
very good novel and the screenplay is
fantastic it's just a great great story
like crime story late 70s early 80s
on spy your European spy story and it's
it's about she's really smart very very
well-written and very nuanced in a
pretty cool character I'm excited those
John the cutting novels are excellent
yeah it's really it's really smart and
it deals with the conflict in Israel and
and in Palestine and I play a Mossad
agent on but it's not Zionist thick or
super pro-israel it's very nuanced and
you understand and my character as well
understands the plight of the other side
and what they're going through